die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Rudi Cerne für
den Sport hallo schönen guten Abend wir
haben heute diese Themen für Sie
energiedeal abgeschlossen Deutschland
bekommt ab Dezember verflüssigtes Erdgas
aus den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
die gasumlage wackelt nun äußert auch
Finanzminister Lindner Bedenken und
fordert stattdessen eine gaspreisbremse
und Weltrekord geknackt der Kenianer
Eliot gibt choge läuft in Berlin
Marathon in zwei Stunden einer Minute
und 9 Sekunden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
um von russischen gasunabhängig zu
werden braucht Deutschland dringend neue
Lieferanten deswegen ist der
Bundeskanzler an diesem Wochenende in
den Golf starten und er kann Erfolge
präsentieren RWE etwa hat in den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten einen
ersten Vertrag ausgehandelt demnach
sollen im Dezember
150.000 Kubikmeter verflüssigtes Erdgas
an das neue lng-terminal in Brunsbüttel
geliefert werden zum Vergleich das ist
weniger als durch die pipeline-nords
shame 1 vor Kriegsbeginn an einem Tag
floss ein Anfang also wenn auch nur ein
kleiner Andrea Meuser esse aus wie ein
entspannter besuchen einem
Naturschutzgebiet aber es war harte
politische Arbeit die zweite Station von
Bundeskanzler Scholz auf seiner ostreise
die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate nach
den schönen Bildern aber dann doch
konkretes es gibt einen ersten Vertrag
über die Lieferung von verflüssigem
Erdgas im Dezember soll das G
Deutschland eintreffen das sei eine neue
Energiepartnerschaft aber keine neue
Abhängigkeit andere liefertechniken
schafften andere Voraussetzungen mit den
Investitionen die wir jetzt in
Deutschland tätigen und die Stück für
Stück im nächsten Jahr Realität werden
werden wir ja eine Infrastruktur für
Gasimporte für Deutschland bekommen bei
der wir nicht mehr wie bei einer
pipeline-verbindung unmittelbar
angewiesen sind auf den konkreten
Lieferanten am anderen Ende der Pipeline
am frühen Nachmittag dann die dritte
Station der Nahost-Reise Qatar schon
lange laufen Verhandlungen über die
Lieferung von verflüssigtem Erdgas Katar
besteht auf langfristigen
Lieferverträgen Berlin will sich nur
kurzfristig binden konkretes gab es auch
heute nicht nur die betreuerung des
Staatsoberhauptes man sei sehr daran
interessiert weiter in Deutschland zu
investieren
und dann noch das Thema Menschenrechte
auf den Baustellen der Fußball-WM Scholz
wusste er muss es ansprechen zur
Kenntnis nehmen wir das ist auch
Fortschritte gibt und tragen und wie
lange gewogen werden musste etwa was die
Situation von Beschäftigten betrifft
auch wenn das noch lange nicht den
Vorstellungen entspricht die wir selber
haben drei Länder zwei Tage eine
schwierige Reise
Anfang Oktober soll eigentlich die
gasumlage starten doch die gerät
zunehmend in die Kritik auch innerhalb
der Koalition heute äußerte
Finanzminister Lindner Zweifel an dem
Aufschlag für Millionen von Gaskunden er
plädiert für eine gaspreisbremse um zu
entlasten offen ist woher das Geld dafür
kommen soll mattes Feldhoff berichtet
es sind Bilder wie diese die derzeit
exemplarisch zeigen wie verzweifelt
viele Menschen auf ihre Gasrechnung
schauen und nicht wissen wie ihnen
geschieht ein Umstand der den
Finanzminister sechs Tage vor der
Einführung die Notbremse ziehen lässt
die gasumlage Macht die Gaspreise noch
teurer da stellt sich die Frage nach der
wirtschaftlichen Sinnhaftigkeit wir
sollten stattdessen über eine
gaspreisbremse nachdenken um die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher und die
Betriebe vor den extremen
Belastungsspitzen zu schützen eine
Erkenntnis die schon seit Wochen von
Kritikern vorgetragen wird seit Tagen
streitet die Koalition über die
Notwendigkeit und die Rechtmäßigkeit der
gasumlage die Idee von
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck notleidende
gasfirmen daraus zu stützen droht
endgültig zu scheitern so leicht will
sich der grüne ampelteil nicht
geschlagen geben die gasumlage kann weg
sobald das Finanzministerium eine
Bereitschaft für Alternativen und diese
Alternative heißt natürlich klar
Finanzierung der Stabilisierung aus dem
Haushalt das sind mindestens 30
Milliarden Euro das heißt der
Finanzminister muss mindestens diesem
Betrag dann selber aus der Staatskasse
bezahlen aus der Union die die Umlage
schon lange für Murk fällt kommt nur
noch Sport wir erleben ein ziemliches
schwarze peter-spiel in dieser
Bundesregierung zwischen ein Habeck und
Herrn Lindner geht das laufend hin und
her wer jetzt schuld daran ist dass sie
gasumlage keine schlaue Idee war richtig
ist sie jetzt rückgängig zu machen
Christian Linder will dafür nicht die
Schuldenbremse verletzen wo er
allerdings die zweistellige
Milliardensumme hernimmt bleibt erstmal
sein Geheimnis
das Moskau hunderttausende Reservisten
in den Ukraine Krieg schicken will sorgt
weiter für Unruhe im Land es gab neue
Proteste und ist häufen sich Beschwerden
auch Männer ohne militärische Erfahrung
würden einberufen nach offiziellen
Berichten dagegen läuft die
Mobilisierung problemlos Julia Schröter
die Teilmobilmachung läuft blendend das
sollen diese Bilder von einem
Rekrutierungsbüro in Köln vermitteln
veröffentlicht heute vom russischen
Verteidigungsministerium die Interviews
sind entsprechend
mich nicht weg sie haben gerufen also
geht's los
doch so reibungslos läuft es in
Wirklichkeit nicht es häufen sich
Meldungen wonach immer wieder Menschen
rekrutiert werden die gar nicht in
Kriterien entsprechen Kranke etwa oder
viel zu alte selbst Unterstützer von
Putin kritisieren inzwischen offen die
Umsetzung der Teilmobilmachung der
ukrainische Präsident selenski hat die
neurekrutierten Soldaten auf Russisch
aufgerufen sich zu ergeben
es ist besser die Einberufung zum Dienst
abzulehnen als auf fremder Erde als
Kriegsverbrecher zu sterben es ist
besser sich in ukrainische
Gefangenschaft zu begeben als von uns
getötet zu werden
unterdessen hat Russlands Außenminister
lavroff vor der UN-Vollversammlung in
New York den Krieg erneut gerechtfertigt
und wütend ausgeteilt gegen den Westen
die Russen Angst des Westens ist
beispiellos und in ihrem Ausmaß grotesk
es ist ihnen nicht einmal peinlich offen
zu erklären dass es nicht nur die
Absicht gibt unserem Land eine
militärische Niederlage zuzufügen
sondern Russland zu zerstören zu
zerstückeln
der Krieg und die Zwangsrekrutierung das
hat auch heute wieder Männer und Frauen
auf die Straße getrieben
in der südrussischen Teilrepublik
Dagestan feuern Polizisten bei einer
Demo Warnschüsse ab der Staat reagiert
mit aller Härte Widerstand soll im Keim
erstickt werden
Italien wählt heute sein neues Parlament
rund 50 Millionen Menschen sind
aufgerufen über die Zusammensetzung von
Senat und Abgeordnetenkammer zu
entscheiden es deutet sich eine eher
niedrige Beteiligung an noch bis 23 Uhr
sind die Wahllokale geöffnet als Favorit
gilt ein rechtes Bündnis angeführt von
Georgia Meloni und ihrer fratelli
d'Italia zusammen mit der leger von
Matthäus Salvini und der Forza Italia
von Silvio Berlusconi könnte es für die
Mehrheit reichen
Sturmfluten und heftige Regenfälle in
Kanada Wirbelsturm fiona hat dort an der
Atlantikküste schwere Schäden
angerichtet hohe wellenrissen mehrere
Häuser mit sich eine Frau wird vermisst
nachdem sie ins Meer gespült wurde der
Sturm entwurzelte viele Bäume in rund
500.000 Haushalten viel der Strom aus in
einigen Gebieten wurde der Notstand
ausgerufen Kanadas Regierung versprach
schnelle Hilfe
damit sind wir bei der Ruder-WM da gab
es aus deutscher Sicht bislang nichts
glänzendes ist heute aufatmen am letzten
Tag eine Goldmedaille gab es dann doch
noch und zwar im einer Oliver Zeitler
holt Ihnen racice den einzigen WM-Titel
in den olympischen Bootsklassen für den
insgesamt enttäuschenden Deutschen
Ruderverband mit einer mit 1 47 Sekunden
Vorsprung siegt er vor Melvin Trailer
aus den Niederlanden
mit Physis und wieder erlangter mentaler
Stärke hat Oliver Zeitler zurückgefunden
in die Erfolgsspur schon im ersten
Teilabschnitt setzt er sich an die
Spitze und gewinnt vor dem Top
favorisierten Europameister Melvin
Trailer aus den Niederlanden und dem
Briten Graham Thomas das war jetzt das
langer sind der Erfolgserlebnis soll
jetzt mal wieder gebraucht habe und ja
deswegen bin ich sehr zufrieden die
Medaille ist lediglich Kosmetik für die
bislang schlechteste WM-Bilanz des
Deutschen Ruderverbandes
der Kenianer Elliot kitschoge gewinnt
den Berlin-Marathon in neuer
Weltrekordzeit vor seinem Landsmann
markkurier und dem äthiopia arbeitet
tigistopien sieht klar bei den Frauen
begleitet von seinen Tempomachern läuft
der 37-Jährige von Beginn an auf
weltrekordkurs die Durchgangszeit bei
der Hälfte 59 51 eine farbe-zeit scheint
möglich aber kippt Dschungel kann das
hohe Tempo der ersten Rennhälfte nicht
halten sein eigener Weltrekord aber
fällt in zwei Stunden einer Minute und 9
Sekunden gewinnt kippture zum vierten
Mal in Berlin verbessert seine alte
Bestmarke um 30 Sekunden bei den Frauen
läuft die Äthiopien
Remko Ebene Pohl ist neuer
straßenrad-weltmeister der 22 Jahre alte
Belgier siegt in bolongong Australien
nach
266,9 Kilometern klar vor dem Franzosen
laport und Michael Matthews aus
Australien
Fußball noch Bundestrainer Hansi Flick
hat mit seiner Mannschaft des
Abschlusstraining für das letzte
Gruppenspiel der nations League morgen
in England absolviert das DFB-Team traf
sich heute morgen in Leipzig zur letzten
Übungseinheit vor dem Flug nach London
nach der Niederlage gegen Ungarn gilt
als sicher das Flick personelle
Veränderungen im Team vornehmen wird und
noch eine Meldung vom Tennis für dich
Barbara das Team Welt besiegt im
lasercup zum ersten Mal Team Europa mit
13 zu 8 was wichtig ja wahnsinn ich
danke dir wir schauen noch aufs Wetter
die Sonne hält sich morgen sehr bedeckt
in der nordwest-hälfte dichte Wolken und
teils länger anhaltender Regen sonst
wechselnd bewölkt und nur vereinzelt
Schauer bei starkem an der Nordsee
stürmischem Südwest 10 bis 18 Grad und
es bleibt auch erstmal unbeständig und
kühl Marietta Slomka freut sich auf Sie
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn wir
sagen tschüss bis morgen wünschen Ihnen
einen guten Start in die